look at this beautiful little gentleman
this is jenga
hi vfs welcome everybody
you know what's always true everything
is better with puppies
and with everything going on this week
and still going on
i just wanted to take a moment to thank
all the poll workers
out there that's right we're celebrating
you all week
you have made everything possible and
our nation
and everyone here at the studio we
appreciate you thank you
thank you to the poll workers
thank you well right now i'm just gonna
check in with how things are going i'm
gonna walk over to the magic wall
just kidding it's a living room full of
more puppies
that's right i mean what is better and
guess what i know oh hello
hello and by the way all these puppies
are named after board games my friend
robin is adopting boggle jd is adopting
jenga there's yahtzee over there they're
the cutest things you've ever seen
they are all available so
if you go to our website you can find
them to
adopt and we'll be popping in with them
throughout the show
hey bffs are there any other dog lovers
out there
maybe an andrew from long island
hi drew hi andrew happy to share a
namesake with you
absolutely and who is that
this is uh this is holly she's almost
eight years old and
she's the absolute joy of my life oh my
goodness
oh hello ellie thank you for coming i
noticed
all so many of our vffs have dogs today
my dogs douglas and lucy come with me to
work all the time it's the best
there's nothing greater than puppies i
mean obviously kids and they come first
now but
my first kids were puppies and let's do
a quick check-in from the news desk to
the puppy pen
oh don't jump on you no no no no
i can't stand it i mean come on aren't
these cuties just irresistible
let's get one more check in oh no no
scramble let's get one more check in on
those cuddly pups okay
guess what go to our website because on
there is the
info to give these guys a home we've
already gotten
two homes today with robin and jd
it's very exciting oh i just love
pokemon
i just want to invite our vfs into the
puppy pile
oh this is boggle this one's going to
my friend robin the one who i forced to
break into a cemetery
yeah that's right you're going home with
her scrabble
boggled boggle taboo twister
uno yahtzee jenga and there was an apple
i think from apples to apples
you know since we have some time left
why don't we do something we're calling
a little
druin a ak q a bffs does anyone have a
question for me
i think there is a katie from florida
hi katie i'm a little jealous of your
shirt right now
it's fabulous i knew you would like this
i know you would love it
i do love it i feel i pick up when
you're putting down
what's your question katie i just have
to say i'm a huge fan lifelong fan
i do have a question i have two sons and
my older son is
always asking for a pet and how can we
make sure that
as a kid because he's only almost four
that they stay responsible and that
you know doesn't transfer to mom and dad
because we don't want to do that so how
how can you ensure your kids
you know take on that responsibility at
a young age
well that is an excellent question um
because
you know we're all always grappling with
important parenting and
wanting to raise thoughtful and
responsible children
uh i think that you know having
him participate with you because four
is young um so that he really
learns from you all the cues and the
things he has to do
and the wee wee pads and the clean up
and the feeding
and make it really easy for him like get
him a little tub where he can just scoop
the food by
unscrewing the cap and just make
everything very
at his level um in the pantry
and very accessible and filling the
water bowls and try to make it fun
and then when he's old enough you're
like you're on kid this is your job
okay i hope that helps i had to think of
that i think so yeah
amazing thank you oh katie good luck and
i have to say puppies bring so much joy
to your home
okay look at this purple face oh we have
another question lolita from virginia
hi lolita i'm drew
lolita i have to compliment you on your
name it is gorgeous
oh thank you so much thank you thank you
so much i love you drew
but i have a question what type of puppy
do you
prefer you know i have to say
um i've i'm a big rescue and foster dog
and the pure breeds can you know
be a little more puppies for a lot
longer
and i find that a mixed breed dog are
a little more interesting in the
personalities and they seem to mellow
faster
so i really do love a mutt i have to say
i'm very preferential
to them and that's really you know what
you're gonna
yeah and that's what you're going to
find at the rescue places so
i really like a mixed breed personally
okay oh thank you i
loved your question katie i loved your
question kate
and i wish you guys all the best this
week and before we go i just want to say
thank you to bark for good
for allowing us to cuddle up with these
pups today and they're donating a bark
box to anyone who adopts so you go to
our website if you're interested
kate hint and all seven are looking for
a loving home although i think we've
adopted two
louie's legacy animal rescue and foster
dogs inc
again all on the drewberrymore show.com
thank you for spending the day with us
take this with you goodbye
[Applause]
[Music]